if these come up missing
[Music]
the wardrobe on this show is going crazy
fashion is such an important part of the
culture you know who would we be to not
really highlight that component through
our show and it's showcasing all of our
styles individually as people but also
as characters and also as a community
and that's super exciting to see cass is
so fresh you know i mean we've got the
best looking cats too their clothes are
a huge part of their story and what we
want to say ultimately through each
character you know jabari is a dude from
philly you know i mean you can't walk
around super flashy in west philly
that's not going to happen so that's
reflected and we see a stylistic shift
as he moves to bel air and all of a
sudden he's wearing clothes that are
more saturated tonally with their colors
no fit is complete if you ain't rocking
some heat on your feet today i'm wearing
a ted baker suit with a nice sleek black
tie and then i got the jordan ones on
will
when he was rocking the jordans on
camera in front of the whole nation you
know what i mean that was huge for the
sneaker community for me to fill those
shoes that's an honor of mine one of my
favorite shoes that i've worn so far on
the show it's probably been the
lightning force i wear the lightning
fours in episode two in the scene where
i recently got my swagger back and i'm
walking to school and i'm feeling good
my grails
carlton's fashion sense he's trendy he's
a trendy and expensive dude his fashion
is his armor
you know a lot of matching sets a lot of
high-end designer a lot of
stuff that this allowed let's say cb
kim's got a favorite carlton banks baby
we rich in the pilot will is wearing one
of carlton's old suits you know i think
that's that's one of the first examples
you see of will coming into this world
sort of taking something of carlton's
and then making it his own but i think
it sets up this really really
interesting sort of bull fighting match
between them you gonna ask me how i've
been or no you're gonna tell me why you
wearing my clothes oh [ __ ] uh yeah
hillary set me up something about a
failed growth spurt will and carlton
diametrically opposed they both love
sneakers but they love different types
of sneakers carlton's approach to
sneakers is the more high-end he's in
the balenciagas the one that looks like
socks i think that's such a really
subtle and interesting way to show again
these are two people who are black they
both love sneakers and neither approach
is wrong their approach is just
different i think the best dressed cast
member is coco
she got that dress i feel like even the
og hilary whenever she stepped out it
was a moment it's so needed to see like
black women and being sexy and like
being classy being professional all
those things in one i would say new
hillary style is modern as well as
really girly chic really pink really
like pastel
but
adult you know what i'm saying mature
custom
dress the designer she designed this
dress in a day have you tried it on they
altered it and then i wore it the next
day basically
turn around so my favorite look is
definitely this blue and white girly
two-piece set from balmain i feel like
it just
was perfect like perfect for the scene
perfect for hillary it's very modern by
giving like the the two-piece like set
type of look would also like throwing it
back to like a clueless school girly
type
vibe that i just felt like was really
perfect and the details were amazing
like super blinged out with like pearls
and
diamonds and ice it was just
and then i had this blue diamond
necklace oh it was just chef's kiss i
just love ashley's style how she plays
around with a bunch of stuff she puts
pieces together and she wears a lot of
boots i love boots personally and the
boots that ashley wears
make her taller just all the colors and
the pieces being together just really
show different sides of her personality
phil doesn't just wear something for the
sake of wearing it for a reason and it
makes a statement and it complements him
and i could definitely see a philip
banks
collection of suits
all those guns see this is when i get
it's environment
look at this demonstration and then
second one
starts off as michelle obama and she
blossoms maybe into like an alicia keys
like who should she be in this world of
bel air who should she be if her
husband's running for office we change
who we are for the role that we're
trying to take on in life so she's been
trying to fit into this one role like
she's the queen of all aunties every
detail that you see within a frame
is something that should be
additive to the story so when you see
somebody in a certain pattern or a
certain color like how can that inform
character how can that help inform story
or the emotional arc of that character
so i hope people can feel that and feel
very
specific carved out identities that are
told through the wardrobe
[Music]
you